February 1st 2008 you know Chris Wallace
calls me to his office and gives me the
news that I was traded to the Los
Angeles Lakers
that obviously changed changed my life
in my career I know some people in the
league were upset about the trade
but it happened right
and that's um
and that's why I got to know the person
who elevated my game
like no other
who taught me what it took to win at the
highest level
who showed me how hard you had to work
and the mentality you needed to have in
order to be the best
the commitment you had to make what it
meant and what it took to be a leader
Kobe
that night that night I joined the team
in DC and I got to the hotel after
midnight you know he was texting me
saying Hey I want to come by your room
and I want to welcome you I want to say
hello when I'm I want to welcome you to
the team I said you know what I mean
it's going to be late it's going to be
like past 1 a.m you sure you don't want
to wait for tomorrow
you said no no I'm it's not going to be
so late I'm coming I'm coming over set
up okay sounds good uh the team had a
game next day at noon so all right
so he just wanted to make sure that
right away firsthand I got the message
so welcome to the team
I'm happy you're here now let's go win a
championship together
so I said all right I'm in man I'm in
have a good night that was it
that was it it's that was it no no crap
straight straight to the chase
I wouldn't be here without you brother
I wish more than anything that you and
Gigi are here today with us
I miss you and love you
thank you
thank you thank you Vanessa for being
here tonight
um proud to be your brother
thank you
and an uncle and an uncle to your
wonderful girls I love you guys so very
much